Pawn Stars fans were caught by surprise
in early 2016
when series star Austin Lee Russell
better known as Chumlee was arrested for
drug and weapon possession as part of an
ongoing sexual assault investigation the
truth is we never really know the people
we like seeing on TV time to put the
Hawking on hold as we look at the untold
truth about the cast of Pawn Stars human
skulls and Japanese porn according to
Rick Harrison co-owner of the world
famous Gold & Silver Pawn Shop
his business has seen all kinds of weird
items come and go surprisingly human
skulls and bizarre types of Japanese
pornography are the oddest items anyone
has ever brought into a shop to sell
which if you think about it means he's
gotten off easy over the years unreal
reality what you see on TV isn't quite
what you get
given that attempting to film the actual
day-to-day life at a pawn shop will
result in some pretty boring television
it should come as no surprise that the
items you see brought into the Gold &
Silver Pawn Shop on the show have been
vetted beforehand this allows the guys
to bring in all kinds of experts who
help them decide a fair price for the
items additionally due partly to Nevada
privacy laws the Pawn Stars crew is
prevented from working at the actual
gold and silver counter while the
cameras roll instead they filmed their
scenes on a set that's been designed to
look like the store it's no surprise
that not all the gold and silver you see
on your screen is the real deal
Rick married into a mess after Harrison
weds legal worker Deanna Burdett in 2013
tabloids reported that the lovebirds
were embroiled in a legal battle
involving Burnitz ex-husband who is free
on bail while awaiting trial for a
variety of sexual rape charges the
Anna's ex was ultimately sentenced up to
15 years in prison for his offenses
fired for being naked sort of Pawn Stars
cast member olivia black lost her gig on
the show after nude photos of her
surfaced
exposing her previous career as a model
for suicide girl
she later revealed that she was still an
employee at the store as she was really
only fired in front of the
Rose black resumed her modeling career
and sued to get back on the Shelf
ultimately leaving her job at the store
several months later sued for melting
stolen coins when you deal with the
public for a living you really never
know what's going to happen Harrison got
a harsh reminder of this in 2014 when
his store was sued for melting down a
collection of gold coins that their
former owner alleged I've been stolen
and sold off by his knees
although pawn shops in Nevada are
required to hold onto items for 30 to 90
days in case their owners want to get
them back gold coins aren't subject to
that law meaning the lawsuit might have
been an embarrassing hassle but it
didn't pose much of a legal threat to
the store Corey Harrison stunt cyclist
in 2014 Harrison was riding his bike
while collecting supplies for his
birthday party
when a piece of his Thunder came off
sending him into a high-speed tailspin
thinking fast he avoided sailing into
traffic by jumping off his bike and he
still went to the party before heading
to the hospital where he learned he had
a broken hand Harrison is no stranger to
wrecks either in 2011 he was in the news
for wiping out in the rain during a ride
between Vegas and San Diego maybe it's
time to start pawning the bikes Pawn
Stars big expansion reality TV can be
fickle so credit is due to Harrison for
striking while the iron's hot and using
his fame as the foundation for a
business empire that now includes pawn
Plaza a shopping center made out of old
shipping containers that sit next door
in the shop among the tenants Rick's
rollin smoke barbeque and tavern where
Harrison intends to sit in as a
part-time bartender internet depth hoax
in the spring of 2013 words circulated
that Chumlee died of a heart attack
these rumors were quickly debunked with
a tweet from the Pawn Stars cast member
who told followers may we live long rich
forever time to start spending those
riches on a good lawyer not Chumley's
first rodeo
in 2012 cameras captured Chumlee in a
brawl with an unidentified man who
approached him and a group of friends
while they were hanging out on Hollywood
Boulevard
he later insisted he was fighting in
self-defense and that the man was a
stranger who's trying to climb into his
car self-defense isn't a bad way to talk
your way out of a scuffle but good luck
explaining the meth the gun and
everything else Chumlee thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one
you just saw and leave us a comment to
let us know what surprised you the most
other Pawn Stars